curfews arbitrary arrests restrictions
on the right of assembly following
months of intense anti-government
protests Ethiopia has declared a state
of emergency the government says it's a
necessary step for the nation stability
the kind of threats that we're facing
the kinds of attacks that are now
targeting civilians targeting critical
infrastructures targeting investments
are not such that they could be
effectively handled through ordinary law
enforcement procedures anger over
development plans for the capital
sparked the recent protests the Amhara
and Roma people the two largest ethnic
groups of the country say they are
marginalized by the government
opposition parties are critical of the
state of emergency will not bring peace
to this country I suspect it will
intensify the issues further the
conflict will worsen the dangers will
multiply and lives will be lost Idaho
hundreds of people have been killed in
Ethiopia since the unrest broke out last
year during her visit to the country on
Tuesday German Chancellor Angela Merkel
will discuss the political situation
Merkel will also talk about the
migration crisis Ethiopia is one of the
world's top host countries for Refugees